is resulting in hospitalization
increases across all age groups
including children age zero to four
the emergence of the omicron variant
again emphasizes the importance of
vaccinations and boosters which decrease
the risk of infection severe disease and
death caused by covet 19.
just last week we made important
progress towards increasing booster
coverage through key four key actions
first we expanded eligibility of booster
doses to those 12 to 15 years old
second cdc strengthens its booster
recommendation for adolescents now
recommending that adolescents age 12 to
17 years old should receive a booster
shot five months after their initial
pfizer bioentech vaccine series
third we recommended that moderately or
severely immunocompromised five to
eleven-year-olds receive an additional
primary dose of vaccine 28 days after
their second shot
and fourth we shorten the recommended
recommended time between a primary mrna
series and a booster dose from six
months to five months
each action increases access to vaccines
and booster doses at a time when
protection
is critical
as we continue to monitor monitor this
rapidly evolving virus we are working
quickly to adapt with it
over the holidays cdc updated our
quarantine and isolation guidance first
for healthcare workers and then for the
general public
i know this update has resulted in
numerous questions so i would like to
take a moment to walk through it now
four people who tested positive for
covet 19 cdc recommends isolation for
five days
if you are asymptomatic or if your
symptoms are resolving for example
you're without a fever for 24 hours you
no longer need to isolate
however you should continue to wear a
well-fitting mask at all times when
around others including at home and in
public for an additional five days
we recommend that you avoid activities
where you are unable to wear a mask and
that you avoid travel for the full 10
days
in addition cdc changed the recommended
duration of quarantine quarantine is
what you do after you're exposed
people who are not up to date on
recommended covet 19 vaccines
should quarantine for five days if they
come in contact with someone with
covenanting
people who do not develop symptoms but
by day five should get tested if you
test positive you should begin isolation
people who test negative may end
quarantine and should continue to wear a
well-fitting bask when around others for
an additional five days
these recommendations are consistent
with over 100 studies collected over the
past two years
indicating that people are most
infectious during their first few days
of infection and significantly less
infectious six to ten days after
infection
a core part of cdc's mission is to
translate science into recommendations
for best practices and real world
circumstances
over the holidays we saw the growing
surge of omicron and took swift
science-based action to address the very
real possibility of staffing shortages
in hospitals and in other essential
areas of the workforce including schools
pharmacies public safety public labs
grocery stores and other sites where
shortages could have and have proven to
have dire public health consequences
this is the right guidance for what we
currently know about transmission and
the real world circumstances we
currently face
as we will learn more we will continue
to update accordingly
omicron is likely not to be the last
curveball this virus throws at us but we
have the tools to prevent further spread
of this virus
this means for everyone five and older
please get vaccinated for those 12 and
older get your booster shot and please
continue to adhere to the multi-layered
prevention measures including masking
and yes washing your hands thank you and
i look forward to your questions
thank you dr fauci
madam chair ranking member burr members
of the committee thank you for giving me
the opportunity to discuss with you the
role of the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases in
the conduct and support
of research addressing our nation's
response to covert 19.
in our most recent hearing before this
committee on november the 4th
i discussed the importance of booster
shots to enhance immunity against the
delta variant that wanes over time
indeed booster shots have dramatically
reconstituted the waning immunity
and has increased protection over and
above the original level afforded
by the primary vaccine regimen
today
we are faced with a different challenge
a new variant called omicron that is
rapidly spread throughout the world
including a massive unprecedented surge
in the united states
this variant possesses a large number of
mutations
that are associated with an increased
efficiency of transmission
immune evasion from certain monoclonal
antibodies convalescent plasma
and antibodies induced by our current
vaccines
thus far
data from our own laboratories at niaid
as well as from laboratories throughout
the world have indicated
that vaccine-induced antibodies lose a
considerable amount of potency
in neutralizing the omnicom variant
although this is of obvious concern
the encouraging news is that a third
shock boost of an mrna vaccine
significantly reconstitutes
and enhances the ability of antibodies
from boosted individuals to neutralize
the omicron variant
strongly suggesting
that boosters will play a major role
in protecting our population at least
from severe disease
in the context of the ongoing massive
surge
of the omicron variant that we are
currently experiencing
underscoring why it is so important for
the unvaccinated to get vaccinated and
for those who are already vaccinated to
obtain the booster shot
therapies in general are an important
part of our armamentarium against covid
in this regard the nih has been heavily
involved
in the development and or clinical
testing
of several effective monoclonal
antibodies against saws kobe 2.
however
we have ascertained that certain of the
authorized monoclonal antibodies are
negatively impacted
by the omicron variant
direct antiviral therapies also are an
extremely important tool in the fight
against cover 19.
importantly it appears that the
mutations expressed by the omicron
variant do not interfere
with the oral antiviral drugs paxlovid
and malnupiravir
that nih-funded investigators played an
early role in developing
and that have recently received
emergency use authorization from the fda
nor do they appear to interfere
with the fda fully approved drug
remdesavia
shown by nih sponsored studies
to be highly effective in preventing
severe disease
looking ahead in the context of the
inevitable continual emergence of new
variants
the importance of developing a panned
coronavirus vaccine namely one
that would be effective against all
saw's kobe 2 variants and ultimately
against all coronaviruses
becomes even more apparent
my colleagues and i
recently published a paper in the new
england journal of medicine
emphasizing the urgent need for such an
effort
in this regard
we have made significant progress in
that direction
we have identified antibodies that
neutralize multiple different
coronaviruses
and in addition
niaid has issued new awards to fund pan
coronavirus vaccines at four academic
institutions
these awards will fund
multi-disciplinary collaborative teams
to conduct research
focused on coronavirus virology and
immunology
image and design
and innovative vaccine and adjuvant
platforms
as well as technologies to discover
design and develop
panned coronavirus vaccine candidates
finally i would like to close by looking
forward to how we might best enhance our
preparedness
for what inevitably will be the
emergence of future pandemics
the niaid will play an important role in
the multi-billion dollar all of
government plan
for pandemic pandemic preparedness
our mission
is the rapid development and
implementation of successful
countermeasures
against several prototype pathogen
families of viruses that threaten the
health and safety not only of our nation
but of the entire world
thank you for your attention and i would
be happy to answer your questions
following the presentations
thank you dr
woodcock good morning chair murray
ranking member and members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify
fda's thousands of employees remain
steadfast in fighting this pandemic our
work continued during the holiday season
and led to critical advancements in
combating the virus
the agency has been closely monitoring
the potential impact of the omicron
variant on the currently available
vaccines diagnostics and therapeutics
i'll provide a brief update and actions
the agency has taken
in these three areas since i last
testified before this committee
first regarding vaccines the currently
authorized and approved vaccines remain
highly effective at preventing serious
outcomes associated with a covid19
infection including hospitalization and
death
additionally data evaluated by the fda
suggests that an additional booster shot
following the completion of primary
vaccinations
provides further protection
against these outcomes
following these data fda updated the
pfizer bio and tech and moderna vaccine
euas to shorten the time between
completion of a primary series and a
booster dose to at least five months
rather than six months
fda also updated the pfizer bio and tech
uh eua so it's of now available for a
primary series in children five ages
five and older and for the use of a
booster dose in all individuals 12
through 15 years of age after completion
of primary vaccination as you've already
heard from dr olinsky
as the cdc followed up on this the
agency also authorized the pfizer
vaccine for a third primary series dose
for certain immunocompromised children
that are 5 through 11.
these vaccines have met fda's rigorous
standards and the bottom line is getting
vaccinated or receiving a booster with
one of the currently available vaccines
is the best thing the public can do
right now to protect themselves and
those they care about it is not too late
to get vaccinated or get boosted
second diagnostic tests which are
another key line of defense in this
pandemic
increasing
access to accurate rapid at-home tests
continues to be a priority for fda
since i last testified the agencies
authorized four additional
over-the-counter at-home tests bringing
the total number to 15 and the agency
continues to prioritize the review of
these type of tests
we also partnered with the nih to
establish itap which streamlines
validation and author
authorization of antigen tests with
potential for large-scale manufacturing
we expect shorter review times for such
eua requests due to our partnership with
itap
in fact the first two tests that
participated in this program were
authorized in two days or less from the
time fda received the final data
so this is a very good model for
government assistance of
diagnostic manufacturers
in this new program itap will prioritize
new over-the-counter test submissions
that could be manufactured at
significant scale
to accelerate the availability of high
quality accurate and reliable
tests for the public as quickly as
possible
third as new variants continue to emerge
it's crucial to expand the country's
arsenals of covet 19 therapeutics
especially for those unable to get
vaccinated or who can't respond to
vaccination
since i last testified three
therapeutics have been authorized for
use in the treatment of cova 19 for
emergency use
the first of these euas eview
shield was authorized for the prevention
of covid19
the other two therapies paxlavid and
molnopiravir as you heard from dr fouch
here the first authorized
treatments for cova 19 in the form of a
pill that can be taken orally which is a
major step in the fight against this
global pandemic these authorizations
provide new tools to combat
covid19 at a crucial time
and it should make antiviral therapy
more accessible to people at high risk
for progression
now while these um are important tools
they're not substitute for vaccination
and people for whom vaccination is
recommended and i continue to urge the
public to get vaccinated if eligible
and fourth we continue our mission of
protecting the public from fraudulent
medical products
since march we've refused
admission of more than 23 000 lines of
fda regulated products that we're trying
to get into the country
illegally and finally i want to assure
the public the fda is committed to
continue to use every tool in our
toolbox to fight this pandemic
with the best available diagnostics
life-saving therapeutics and vaccines
thank you and i look forward to your
questions
thank you assistant secretary o'connell
chair murray ranking member burr and
distinguished members of the committee
it is an honor to testify you before you
today on efforts within asper to respond
to the pandemic since the emergence of
the omicron variant
when omicron first emerged as we have
done with each new variant we
immediately evaluated its impact on our
current vaccines therapeutics and
diagnostics and adjusted our response
accordingly
data suggests that our current vaccine
doses with a boost confer protection
against omicron as a result we have
continued distributing the three
authorized and approved vaccines
over 600 million doses of vaccine have
been developed and delivered since the
start of the pandemic
we have ample supply of both primary and
booster doses
contributing to more than 200 million
americans now being fully vaccinated
however we have had to make adjustments
to our therapeutic supply in light of
omicron
two of our workhorse monoclonal
therapies one from lily the other from
regeneron are not as effective against
omicron as a result we have increased
our supply of gsk's monoclonal which is
effective
we continue to purchase all that we can
from gsk
though this supply is still limited we
are on track to have 250 000 courses
available this month
a fourth monoclonal by astrazeneca is
targeted for immunocompromised
individuals
at high risk and is taken prior to
exposure to prevent infection
it has retained effectiveness against
omicron and we will have made nearly
half a million courses available through
the end of this month
all four monoclonals are currently
available for states and jurisdictions
to order free of charge on a weekly
basis to treat either omicron or delta
infections also
we now have antivirals by pfizer and
merck that are effective against omicron
and are being delivered to states free
of charge every other week we have
procured 3.1 million courses of merck
that are now available
last week we doubled our commitment to
order 20 million courses of pfizer's
product we have
265 000 courses available through this
month and anticipate delivering the
first 10 million courses to states by
mid-summer
we remain in frequent communication with
states and territorial health officials
on the distribution of therapeutic
products and continue to focus on
ensuring
these life-saving therapies are
available to americans across the
country
the dramatic rise in cases due to
omicron has put a significant strain on
our testing capacity despite significant
effort and investment there's more work
to do and we are working every day and
night with manufacturers to increase the
availability of tests
as soon as we saw the dramatic increase
in cases in south africa and europe we
reached out to test manufacturers to
understand their surge capacity
and supply chain constraints we are
engaging daily with the lab test
providers to mitigate any supply chain
constraints with their sub-tier
suppliers
we are also working with the commercial
and public health labs to prioritize
their needs we continue to use the
defense production acts authorities when
needed
to further increase test availability we
are procuring 500 million rapid tests to
distribute to american households
as a requirement in this procurement
none of these tests can interfere with
what is available in the current
commercial market so as not to diminish
what consumers are able to access now
we are currently shipping 2.8 million
tests to long-term care facilities per
week as we have throughout the pandemic
we continue to work to send 50 million
rapid tests to federally qualified
health centers and food banks with 7
million having shipped so far and we
will keep working around the clock with
manufacturers and our government
partners to increase and sustain the
number of tests available now and in the
future
and finally in addition to vaccines
therapeutics and testing asper continues
to provide on-the-ground support to
states and communities in need since
july 40 national disaster medical system
teams nearly 880 team members have
deployed to 19 separate states and the
commonwealth of the northern mariana
islands to support a range of functions
including hospital augmentation and
decompression setting up medical
overflow centers for patients and
mortuary support
we continue to send supplies as
requested from the strategic national
stockpile including 300 ventilators to
six jurisdictions since the emergence of
omicron
we are grateful for the support from
this committee in congress and i look
forward to answering your questions
thank you to all of our witnesses we
will now begin a round of five-minute
questions of our witnesses and i again
ask my colleagues to keep track of your
clock and stay within those five minutes
as the omicron variant of coven 19
continues to spread at an alarming rate
people are looking for clear
straightforward guidance on how to
protect themselves and those around them
it is really critical that we reduce the
infection rates so we can relieve
pressure on our health care workers
protect people with disabilities and
older americans young kids and anyone
else who's been disproportionately
impacted by covenant 19. however i have
heard from so many people who find the
latest cdc isolation and quarantine
guidance confusing and hard to interpret
so dr wolinski can you please clearly
explain cdc's latest guidance on what
people need to do to protect themselves
and others if they are exposed to or
contract covet 19. and let me start with
vaccinated people what is your guidance
to them
thank you turmeric for the opportunity
to clarify maybe if i could just rewind
the clock to just before the holidays
where we were hearing from hospitals
that they were their staff were going
out and that they were in a real crunch
in terms of beds they had plenty of beds
but they didn't have staff to
to staff them um icu beds were starting
to close so
immediately we worked towards our
updated healthcare worker guidance but
when we did so we recognized that we
were going to have challenges um and
that this omicron surge that we were
about to face was threatening many other
places of our health care system i
appreciate the background but i just
want to know straightforward if someone
is exposed to or has coven 19 and
they're vaccinated what do they do if
they are
exposed to covet 19 and they are
completely boosted they should they do
not need to stay home um but they should
get a test at day five if they have
covered our uh guidance is not does not
distinguish between your vaccination
status and our science has demonstrated
that you're maximally infectious two
days before and two to three days after
so by five days after your symptoms if
you're feeling better if your fever is
better if your cough and sore throat are
better then on day six you can go out
but you have to wear a mask you have to
wear a mask reliably and you should not
go to places you can't wear a mask you
probably shouldn't go and visit grandma
you shouldn't get on an airplane for
vaccinated what about unvaccinate same
for unvaccinated for isolation so
isolation being those who have had
disease who have disease
okay
well let me
just say nearly two years ago when this
committee first started having
congressional hearings on coven 19 the
very first thing i asked was where are
the tests
and we've made progress since then and
we're now producing 300 million rapid
at-home tests each month along with
ramping up our lab-based testing but i
am disappointed as i said by the testing
challenges that we're facing uh tests
are hard to find they're costly people
are unable to find the at-home tests
in pharmacies online
they're waiting in long lines
and often after that waiting days for
results so it's you know ineffective
at the end of the day so miss o'connell
i want to ask you what are you doing to
address the frustrations and challenges
we are hearing about covet testing
chair murray thank you so much uh for
this very important question testing
remains a critical priority for this
administration
when we saw the unprecedented cases of
omicron sweep into south africa and
europe we immediately reached out to our
manufacturers to understand any supply
constraints they had and to evaluate
their surge capacity
we have also met daily with them to make
sure that they have what they need
from their suppliers and have used the
defense production act authorities 12
times throughout this pandemic and
support
of testing needs most recently in the
last few weeks for two tests
we were able to unlock supplies and
manufacturing capacity
we continue to invest in
rapid over-the-counter tests which are
in high demand and in the fall we
invested 3 billion dollars to increase
manufacturing line staffing and to
commit to those manufacturing lines for
13 months
as a result we went from 50 46 million
test
over the counter tests available in
october to the 300 million jeremy that
you just
mentioned that are available now
but that's not enough we're continuing
to uh bring tests to the american people
as a result the president has announced
and we're in the process of procuring
the 500 million tests which every
american household will be able to order
and have shipped directly to their house
we have completed four contracts so far
have secured 50 million tests and are in
the process of securing the additional
tests over the next
several days the u.s postal service has
agreed to do the distribution
and the u.s
digital services is going to help with
the website
we anticipate the first test going out
at the end of this month with the
remaining tests going out over the next
60 days okay and i'm out of time but i
do want to just say this i am hearing
from so many schools that are having
trouble staying open they want to stay
open part of it is they have staff that
are sick that's understandable but a big
part of it is they don't have access to
the safety measures like masks and
and and testing supplies what do i tell
them about where they go to get that
chair murray thank you have is schools
having enough supply testing supplies to
stay open is a critical priority
for us uh we've invested 10 billion of
the american rescue plan uh
given to states to support and stand up
testing programs we've also invested 60
650 million dollars in a program called
operation expanded testing which set up
regional hubs of labs that schools could
contract with to run their testing
programs but that doesn't work if there
aren't tests available so asper is
working directly with states to match
additional manufacturing capacity with
states that need it not only that we are
in the process within asper of looking
at our contracts to see if we have any
additional capacity and will commit to
sending that capacity to the school
programs
senator burke
thank you madam chairman
let me just cut to the chase um dr fauci
you said cdc was going to update its
guidance and include antigen testing or
suggested that it will dr
wolinski and cdc came out with the
guidance that didn't include it
was that part of the communications plan
to start with and they diverted or was
that something you just chose to inject
thank you for that question senator burr
in discussions about the real gray zone
uh which
dr wolinski described about after the
five days where you have
a considerable diminution in the
likelihood of being transmitting we had
been in discussions
about what the role of antigen testing
would be
and as a matter of fact when dr walensky
came out with the final guidelines they
include
that if you have a test available you
may take a test so at the end of the day
we were quite in concordance with our
views
well i i think the chair and i share
this we found it very confusing
and i think the american people found it
confusing and i don't say it lightly
when i say
not too many people in america are
listening to what comes out of
washington whether it's congress or out
of the administration as it relates to
coving
so the president makes an announcement
ms mcdonald of 500 million at home test
is this the first time that you've
thought about purchasing at home test or
have you tried to before and it was
rejected
thank you ranking member burr
this is the first time the
administration has committed to
purchasing uh tests to send to the
american households
so
is that asper is that dod
because of all the notifications of
contracts signed
i've seen them from dod i haven't seen
them from hhs
thank you for that question ranking
member we use a we have a relationship
with dod for assisted acquisitions so
asper will request that dod uh put out a
solicitation or manage a contract on our
behalf uh they're able to do it
extraordinarily quickly and we've had an
mou in place with dod for this work that
will run through june 2023 we've used
this relationship to purchase vaccines
and therapeutics then we're now
using it for testing so
the best i can find you mentioned 50
million doses having been contracted i
can identify 27 million out of two
companies media media
and
um
atlantic
trading
neither one of them are manufacturers of
test and i believe the third one revival
is not a manufacturer of test
media actually
came to fame was importation of vodka
and tying cell phones to vodka and like
a lot of other companies they got in the
ppe business
in 2020
with some nominal fema contracts
why should we have any confidence in
these contracts
if in fact we're dealing with companies
that don't manufacture anything and can
you assure me that the tests that
are coming in are not coming from china
thank you uh uh ranking member bur
absolutely these tests uh what we
initially did to be able to
access uh tests for the initial
shipments that will go uh towards the
end of january we worked with warehouses
to see where additional tests were
stored
and assessed that additional capacity
and are bringing that capacity to bear
for these initial tests that are going
out which is why you're seeing contracts
uh with warehouses and not with test
manufacturers
so is what you're telling me they've got
50 million tests and warehouses in the
united states and all we did was access
that that
inventory
that is my understanding well
will you confirm your understanding this
this is a very very important piece
when you've got companies that don't
manufacture tests and all of a sudden
we're giving them 190 million dollar
contract for about 14 million
home tests
and their expertise is importation of
vodka
i
i
i encourage you to look through the list
of people that we're signing up with
are you aware that
some of the larger test manufacturers in
2021 shut down lines because the lack
of purchases for at home test
one of the things we did in the fall
with the three billion dollar investment
that we made was to turn lines on and to
commit to those lines for 13 months so
they wouldn't be turned off again
uh dr woodcock let me just last question
chair um
of the 15 tests that you've currently
approved for over-the-counter
how many detect omnicron
we're still working on that but we
believe all of them detect omnicron we
simply feel they are somewhat less
sensitive than they were to some of the
previous variants of the 50 million
tests that the asper has contracted for
how many of those tests detect omnicron
i don't know which tests there are we
can get back to you on that so you
haven't consulted with what we're
purchasing on the 500 million they
haven't consulted with fda to figure out
whether the tests they're buying
actually detect omnicron i believe they
have i simply don't have that list okay
i thank the chair
senator kaine
thank you
thank you chairman to the witnesses dr
fauci can you provide us a general
breakdown of what percentage of
hospitalized individuals are vaccinated
versus unvaccinated and what percentage
of cova deaths are among vaccinated or
unvaccinated individuals
thank you for that question senator cain
one of the ways
to answer that question be to look at
people
who are in the hospital and take a look
at if you are vaccinated versus
unvaccinated and if you look at
vaccinated versus unvaccinated there's
about a ten times
times greater changing times greater
times 17 times 20 times infection
hospitalization death
thank you dr fauci um
i don't want to ask you a question about
vaccine
severity of illnesses and hospital
admissions however they've had more
limited success in preventing forward
transmission from vaccinated individuals
after breakthrough cases and the
existing vaccines are not as durable as
vaccines in other
areas so we need booster shots to
continue to
protect against the virus is the
administration considering supporting
the development of additional vaccines
that might be able to address the gaps
in the current vaccine's capabilities
senator kaine thank you so much for that
question yes absolutely i think we all
see the need for next generation
vaccines we are also looking for next
generation antivirals and therapeutics
as well
we're in the process of working with dr
fauci's team to develop a unified nih
barda
research agenda
and budget to address these issues to
identify candidates that might already
be in the pipeline
to help support the research into
candidates that are just starting in the
pipeline
to so we can accelerate
the availability of next generation
vaccines and their
you